yo yo we'll be back to thug notes this
week we turning up the heat with
Fahrenheit 451 by Ray Bradbury and a
bleak guy's depiction of America's
future a platinum player named Guy
Montag be hustlin as a farm but up in
this hood firemen don't put out no fires
nah blood they scrap with hoses to burn
books cuz some bad boys be straight-up
illegal I have to get home from the
grind Montague peeps is 17 year old
neighbor Clarisse she drops some sick
truth that make Montag question the
world's wack gas ways and top it to this
Fox may God real eyes that he's just any
happy with his life that one day guy
gets word that some old hag been
hoarding books so he got to step up and
blaze her stash when he buses in and
starts spitting that venomous kerosene
he secretly Jack's a book and pockets it
but before his boys can start smoking
her spot this girl lights a match and
straight burns herself down with her
books damn that's gangster next day
Montag's boss man Beatty rolls up to his
crib all unannounced
he starts Mad Dog and my boy Montague
saying that if he be packing books he'd
better come clean in 24 hours but first
guy want to know the answer to his
unhappiness laying these books so he
hits up some scrappy English professor
named Faber who learns that the book he
swiped be one of the last known copies
of the Bible lay the baby cause guy out
on it and commands him to burn his own
credit down turns out Montag's wife
Mildred write of the mouth I've got
slopes his own pan baby tries to arrest
him but BAM God turns his hose on baby
and that fool is toast
but before a guy can flee the scene a
creepy robot dog that the fuzz used to
hunt booklovers
shanks Montag as he tries to escape my
man shakes off that hound and bills
before the Popo Canaveral as Montague
running from the police he finds that
fool Faber who tells him where to find a
gang of scholarly hoods
who be trying to preserve the knowledge
of the old
Montag finds these players who say they
dedicated themselves to memorizing books
for when the world is ready for them
again with parts of the Bible deep in
his dome God joins their ranks and
starts rolling toward the city where
he's gonna help him rebuild society
those homies always going off on how the
main theme of this book it's censorship
through book burn but if you keepin it
gangsta you know that Bradbury's main
Jam actually be the creation of a mass
culture as technology got mo legit the
world got smaller and minority voices
got louder so to prevent these whiny
[ __ ] from getting all butthurt a
super PC culture was created to keep any
player from spending truth that some
homies just came here but it ain't only
the government that's the blame nah brah
rayray be criticizing our Americans
always Jones at the bangs to be simple
and possible even if it's all bull peep
game a designee man most cats thinking
that we're better technology comes a
more connected Society but on the real
bratty be saying that just cuz we got
the bad is good don't mean it gonna
bring us any closer to each other my boy
Heidegger dropping the same game and as
that save the thing all distances in
space and time are shrinking yet the
frantic abolition of all distances
brings no nearness for example well
Mildred oldies and needs to get our
stomach pump there'd be all kinds of
machines all up in our insides yet the
players that be operating on earth just
don't give a damn like Montague says
nobody knows anyone strangers come and
violate but don't be thinking it's all
bad baby cuz it ain't old guys a walking
symbol for the hope of mankind's rebirth
seeing German Montague straight up means
Monday suggesting that Montague going to
usher in a new beginning for Humanity
and respect this son peace be thinking
at the title of the books final section
burning bright references a poem by
William Blake called the tiger checking
Tiger Tiger burning bright in the
forests of the night what immortal hand
or eye could frame thy fearful symmetry
just like Blake's tiger that reppin both
beauty and savagery that boy Montague
burn and bright as a symbol of both
creation and destruction cuz the player
who used to sling fire to burn books now
only blazes with the flame of knowledge
look blood you're just st. getting it
til you peep the daggers motif of this
whole book the motif of burning on one
hand 5b representing the destructive
nature of this wax society
but it will be straight-up remiss of
your [ __ ] ass not to think about how
fire also represented a hopeful glow of
the human spirit like the light of the
campfire at the end flame don't just
burn it also gives off warmth you know
thanks for watching thug notes stay fly
hit subscribe
[Music]